good afternoon everybody
hi um we're delighted to welcome you for
these last events in our series of
professional developments um for those
who don't know me my name is florian
carl i'm the manager of the yellow
quantum institute and i'll be modding
this panel so we are delighted to
continue this series that is jointly
organized by the uh engineering
workforce development of the center for
quantum network in arizona uh and this
is our last panel the
fifth one uh and we will focus today on
job on job uh in the industry system so
we wanted to offer this series because
there's a lot of question about how to
what kind of classes should i take to
join the workforce and work in quantum
physics or quantum science uh like
should i be more of a physicist more
engineer more of a quantum scientist and
we recognize that there's a lot of um of
people needed from very different
backgrounds to be able to uh achieve
the uh all the of the technical details
that we need to have a robust problem
science called information and and build
quantum systems and it could be very
overwhelming to to consider all this
option for carrier in in quantum
information so uh today we will hear
from a
recent young professional who graduated
and joined industry as well as a career
driven professional
and so we'll
have we'll be here to answer all of all
of your questions
before we start i would like to
introduce matthews who's the student
liaison consul
for the
center for quorum network
and he might say a few words about
the work that he does
for the cqn
hello everyone well my name is matios uh
it's a pleasure to be here with you
tonight today and well cqn is a research
center funded by nsf with the goal to
build a quantum network and i currently
work with a development of algorithms to
work on the uh software part of the
quantum network and essentially
we have uh
working groups in many different aspects
of the field from really a physical uh
research to be actually view the quantum
hardware that you actually need
for a quantum network to the the
spectrum of the impacts that uh a
quantum metric would bring to society
thank you very much for this it's about
you and so if you want to learn more
about them uh visit cqm the cqn website
in arizona
um so uh let's
jump right in and let's introduce our
participants feel free to turn on uh
your webcam and while you do so i would
like to give you a little bit of um a
little bit of advice and and
uh design for the for the series so
we're gonna start with the introduction
of the panelists and then you can use
all the attendees can use the q a uh
feature at the bottom of your screen uh
where you will see uh well you can ask
all your questions so you will go
through during the the hour we'll go
through all of the questions and try to
to answer all of them
so let's start by introducing uh our
panelists
so
let's start with uh teresa for example
if you don't mind so feel free to
remove the webcam and so
go
ahead uh hello
i'm theresa brecht
i'm a researcher doing quantum device
physics at hrl laboratories in malibu
california
this isn't the real ocean it's just a
backdrop on my wall
but the real ocean is just right out
there
and it's nice and warm today
here i work on quantum dot qubits doing
experiments and measurements
and also developing software for those
and i've been doing that at hrl for
almost five years
my background before joining hrl was in
super conducting qubits i graduated from
yale in 2017
and my phd advisor was rob schulpe there
so that's it
thank you very much
zlatko do you want to go next
yeah sure it'd be my pleasure and hi
everybody uh tuning in uh i'm actually
california right now too though normally
based in uh new york uh city and uh i
had the uh the uh it's actually really
great to be back at yale at least
virtually uh i overlapped with teresa we
started rpgs i think at the same time so
i was in the applied physics department
with michelle deborah from 2018 2011
and uh after working sort of very hard
in the last few years of my phd to
you know
finish this last project i was doing
catching university in quantum jump i
think i applied to something like 10 or
15 post doc positions and basically
everywhere in industry so i wish we had
these panels earlier and it's so awesome
and at that time was a different
landscape so i'm really sort of
thrilled that florian and the yqi and
you know the new institute here in
central are organizing these because
this is exactly what i would have loved
to have even more of
um
and then i moved on to
you can hear the story later i moved on
to a research path at ibm quantum
computing
i've uh
since uh had a
little more unorthodox path i've now
founded and i'm the technical lead of
our quantum device design and analysis
project called kiskit metal
which makes it possible for
basically the first time for anyone to
design their own quantum devices
from their computer and really speed up
and accelerate the process and the
innovation
i
also lead and host ibm kisket's quantum
information seminar series and i'm a
lecturer at the global summer school
through kiskit
and recently i'm sort of thankful to
share that
my roles kind of expanded to also found
a new team
that's going after high risk high reward
research
and that's in a management position as
well
while still staying very focused on the
research aspects of it so
a bit unusual and a bit more hybrid in
that sense
uh so
hopefully i will have a few interesting
uh
tips and to send messages to share
thank you very much sladko uh and then
our last panelist um eleni if you want
to uh tell me about government introduce
yourself
sure thank you so much florian
my name is melanie cinch and i serve as
the interim assistant dean for academic
affairs and the director of the career
center at the university of st joseph
which is in the center of connecticut so
i'm actually in the northeast right now
right now i am also serving as a
consultant to yale university and i'm
working with all of their phds and
postdocs
with all disciplines primarily in the
sciences but
i have been a career counselor for just
over 20 years now my specialization is
working with phds and postdocs in the
sciences
i actually wrote a book on
how to find a job for phds in any branch
of science called next gen phd and so if
any of you
are interested or want to connect please
feel free to get in touch with me if you
have questions following today's panel
i love connecting with scientists at any
level if there are undergraduates on the
call or graduate students or post-docs
i'm also happy to connect with zlatko
and teresa and florian and matthias
because
you know i love learning more about
science so i'm not a quantum scientist
on the on the panel but i'm interested
in hearing about the paths of zlatko and
teresa so thank you for having me
florian
thank you uh that's my pleasure um so
let's jump right in on the in the
questions um so
i think that's gonna be the first
question i have is like what it's like
to work in industry because uh for like
since uh like people asking that
question i've been at school for longest
time you go to high school college grad
school maybe and what what is it like
what's the difference because all of you
were in labs in students and so uh who
wants to start with this virtual
question like what's the main difference
what's the what you should look for and
uh
and all of that
who wants to jump first
all right i can maybe lead it off if
you'd like and then theresa you can jump
in
um
i i think maybe the first thing to just
acknowledge is that it's not monolithic
whether it's in academia or an industry
and i was thinking about this a little
bit because you know there is the
experience i think i had starting at
yale in my graduate degree in 2010-2011
is very different in a sense from the
experience a student starting today
would have the whole landscape of
quantum has changed a lot
and so i think maybe that's the
caveat to begin with is that
it's easy to apply the blanket statement
of industry but really there's so many
different flavors and and that's part of
what you experience is it feels like a
bigger world in some sense
and it's a lot more dynamic
part of what you definitely see in a lot
of industries especially as you move
into more like technology industry and
the kind of industry that quantum is
headed into
is that it's a little closer to like the
machine learning tech industry where
things happen in like two-year cycles
three-year cycles so the pace is
definitely one
major change that you have in terms of
sort of schedules and pace
and um
also you you know you work in much
larger groups and teams typically uh
it's definitely more oriented on like
they have potentially creating stuff you
know it's a little less significance
driven than you know published this
paper or so forth
um
and i think at the same time though yeah
it really depends because there are many
different cultures you've had a startup
panel you know that's going to have a
different kind of slant on it versus a
large organization like ibm which is
huge and it's very more global and
worldwide so you're going to work with
people that come from
tons of different backgrounds so this is
one of the maybe biggest differences you
know i'm not constantly surrounded by
like-minded people who had the exact
same training for the last 20 years as
me in physics i'm working with you know
software developers product designers
physicists engineers material scientists
who have different trainings whose
values
value system is a bit different than
mine we don't know we're not all after
the same thing
and so i think kind of readjusting my
own values
in this environment is one thing that
that i think
it inadvertently will happen and that's
also true in academia too i think as you
go to the next stage those will have to
update
um but it's certainly a lot of sort of
interaction a lot more
team focused in a sense
and
um uh maybe i'll pass the ball up to
theresa because you know i could
probably keep going here for another 10
minutes about this but
uh electricity
um yeah with
like riffing off the first thing you
said about it not being a monolithic
industry
versus academia
[Music]
part of that is that there are many
partnerships and programs that foster
collaboration between academic groups
and industry
[Music]
and that can take many forms of either
sharing technology or
doing like postdoc
visiting
at a
[Music]
research lab in in the industry part um
so there's there's a lot of activity
going on there and a lot of
those sorts of collaborations are now uh
being encouraged by the government and
new
programs um one thing that i really
appreciate about working in industry
over academic labs that i
have been in is that
you get to participate in really
efficient technological development in a
larger team where there's career experts
in their specialized roles that can be
really relied upon to perform their
function at the highest level
like
we have a
hardware team that has been
doing hardware development for decades
and gone through many technological
innovations over that time and they know
how to like carry things forward
we have a fabrication team
that's also very high in expertise we
have a software team
um and they're all really good and it's
not like that in academia where
like by design
there's
a lot of education going on and there's
a constant export of talent so that's
where you go and like learn
everything
and there are many
that's where all the smartest people in
the world are right is that the
universities um
but then they once a person becomes an
expert in something
they leave or go and learn something
else
and i guess what i appreciate about the
industrial environment is that like
experts stay
doing what they're expert at
and then
by constructing the teams efficiently
we're able to work together to like
build something that's much bigger than
you can generally achieve in a research
group
yeah that's a that's a really good point
i think we we've saw that in the
different panels that we had over the
the last year um talking about like if
you're joining an academy group as a pi
uh or if you're joining a startup or
industry you have really really
different roles because the goals are
not the same i think industry academia
has more of an educational purpose to
train people startups will try to
disrupt and find new ways and industry
has more of a product and like
productivity in mind to have some
something and so i think that's
something you want to consider also for
you
for your research and careers like what
what's the end goal what would you like
to do in your life do you want to
teach students do you want to create
stuff do you want to create a product
that could that could be used widely uh
by the job population of by a system and
so that's something to to also keep in
mind and so since you have so many uh
options on that um can you talk a little
bit about what your day-to-day like is
in industry for people who have no idea
like
because we like the i think the
monolithic idea comes from the fact that
we have one word to decry all of that
but there's so many different jobs and
so what what do you do um like if you
have a typical jobs
yeah i can maybe jump in here and build
off of what you and teresa said um
and um and also you know like teaching
and all these different things like
initially i think before joining the
this industry
uh sort of research side of it i you
know i thought there was less of that
but actually we have a giant team
focused on education
and one thing i never anticipated is
i've i've taught at two summer schools
now on like introduction to quantum
hardware and introduction to quantum
noise first one had like four thousand
something students the second one had
like five thousand plus students uh
global and worldwide so i think one
thing i found is that there's a lot of
there's just a pretty big world and
usually if you really want to
to
be happy you kind of have to align you
know your interests with the larger
interest and oftentimes you can you know
we're all you know if you're doing a
degree in in something like quantum
you're usually pretty smart resourceful
person so you can find kind of those uh
potentials so that's why a typical day
for me at least has evolved a lot um you
know initially i've had days where i was
just very focused on work nowadays it's
it's
a lot of more mission building and team
building as well
um kind of trying to scale uh as well i
think the interpersonal becomes a lot
more of your time as well i think
typically in industry because you're
really working in teams and you try to
take your mission to greater things it
becomes more of a mission to that um you
know i've had sort of spur sprints where
it's been just software development and
sprints where it's been a lot of like
reading papers or physics
uh so at least in my case it's it's been
quite colorful and it keeps
evolving and shifting
um and so it's been a lot more dynamic
in that sense so i'm not sure if that's
helpful uh but hopefully it helps paint
a picture
i mean everything is very helpful
because what
what we're trying to do is like trying
to see like how people who have similar
background experience their their new
role in history and so i think it's very
helpful for people to know like exactly
what it is because somebody who doesn't
like to teach and end up in your
position might be disappointed that
he was like they were finding something
slightly different so yeah it's very
it's very nice to have yeah and
i think
oh go on
oh no keep going yeah you're sure yeah
yeah yeah i guess sort of the thought i
i had here and one piece of advice i
kind of heard i think when i was
uh interviewing and applying was you
know there's no perfect position for you
uh you ideally you define your own
position and that's the only time you're
really gonna have that perfect position
and
and uh i've had the chance to kind of
keep reshaping it so
i think maybe that's one thing to keep
in mind is like you have an agency in
this it's not like you have to fit in a
fixed bucket and fit the mold like you
have agents you have flexibility um so
i'll leave it at that
and that's something that we'll talk
about in a in a few moments later we're
gonna let uh turtle talk about
experience uh in uh in hl uh and then
we'll talk about how you can craft your
your job to really match what your
interests are
yeah i think that's a really excellent
point that you're emphasizing zlatco
that that you have agency to craft your
own experience um that's especially true
after you've sort of like
done your service of a year maybe at the
company to like
show that
you're smart and can work with people
um and then like
you can kind of
move into
[Music]
what you figure out is your ideal role
as
you figure that out or if you want to
try out new things within the same
company
thankfully like like you said zlatko
i've been
able to keep my experience kind of
dynamic and try out some different
things and day to day is not always the
same
when i first started the company i was
mostly doing experimental measurements
measuring the quantum devices
so i would go in
and do electrical tests on the devices
sit down at a dilution refrigerator
or remote into a computer where i was
accessing a device that's pulled down in
a refrigerator
and do electrical
tests on it um
one difference between my experience
here and
graduate school is that we have a lot
more meetings because we have these
specialized teams
we spend more time
getting together to
[Music]
directly provide feedback between the
different teams so as part of the
measurement team i was
reporting the results of measurements
back to a fabrication team and also
interfacing a lot with a theory and
modeling team so that we could validate
their models
yeah
so that's that's been fun and as my
experience has evolved i'm now more
interested in
in software
i think that's the interesting thing
about industry is that you can like sort
of find if you especially if you join uh
big big groups of big companies you have
different different nodes and then you
can sort of uh pick and involve in the
same company uh in a way that would not
be
necessarily possible in academia i think
because you you cannot change your your
group goals like every every now and
then um and so i think now we can uh
jump into more of the the nitty-gritty
of like how did you land that job and
like how how did you prepare for the job
search uh why were you interested in and
then also what are they what are the
advice that you can give to people who
are seeking job in industry how can they
prepare
to
to work on that
anybody want to start
great i'll i can leave that off if you
want um because i started on the other
side and now i'm
more on the hiring side
um
and yeah i have two job postings up
actually so one is on kisket metal like
more software developer physicist focus
the other one is really more researcher
level focus and those are two different
roles so for the different roles that
you're applying for you're going to have
different processes
um exactly
and
[Music]
i think one
you know one the first thing you can
always start with to prepare is just
yourself in your own background and
material usually if if you're in science
or a researcher you know you will get
asked to tell people about your research
your work
and so you want to make sure that you
know if that's fresh in your mind you're
confident about it oftentimes you give a
talk
or a presentation so i had to give a
talk in a presentation you know i i had
probably given that talk and
presentation like
18 19 times before uh giving it many
other you know rounds of interviews
sort of you know i went maybe extra i
don't think you need to do it 20 times
but uh you can really prepare that and
have sort of a sense of questions ready
and
um i think the other thing you know
folks look for a lot isn't just the
technical competence that's kind of like
let's get you in the door but that's the
bar right it's also
you know is this a person that we can
get along with is this a person that uh
seems like
they actually want this um you know are
they applying for the right reasons uh
are they motivated like are they eager
about this because you can have the
right skills but if you don't have the
affinity for the mission you're gonna
end up leaving or you're gonna just not
enjoy the job and not do a great job so
affinity is another key thing like
demonstrating that in some way
um and um
and then as you get to more like
software or more um
more of the different sort of more uh
you know desirable positions especially
like in in the new climate you're often
going to have a coding interview a
behavioral interview and a technical
interview and then if you pass those you
talk to like more team members more for
like culture fit and you know can we get
along because we all need to play
together
and so the coding interview there's like
many books and coding interviews
for you know if you're going for a
software position those really matter
right like you you want to know whatever
language it is python you might you know
there's
there's like thousands of resources
online for coding interviews that will
walk you through the basics if you're a
physicist sometimes those coding
interviews are more like okay you know
can you be proficient enough to do your
job but that's not weight as heavily
you might have a physicist interview
where you get asked you know what's an
ising model what are spin interactions
you know how do you measure t1 or t2
depending on your measure you know if
you go into a measurement team you might
want to
so oftentimes you want to understand
because the job posting simply quite
vague you want to understand from the
hiring manager up ahead like what's
really the general focus of this role
um and then
you know sometimes you have behavioral
interviews so you can kind of look those
up uh depends on you know different
companies do it differently
there's no place that has the exact same
processes
um but really the idea there is just to
make sure that you know you
you sort of have your your a good
mindset uh right and maybe i'll lead it
off to teresa too
to add on more here
sure um i like what you said um
and i would add to that like
don't try to squeeze yourself into
a box that you think the ideal candidate
for a given position
is describing um oftentimes the job
requisitions are written in a way that i
think you said opaque sacco
arthur like that too i'm not sure why
they pass through some kind of
hr filter before they go out there
anyway like
generally what places are more looking
for is
what kind of a scientist are you
do you have the affinity
for
uh doing something that is matching with
the mission of the organization and are
you a good cultural fit um
so
yeah i i guess don't try to squeeze
yourself into a box because
you don't know what that box looks like
and
the company wants to hire a good
scientist
uh
and once you're at the company you
generally will have some
uh freedom to
[Music]
be you at your best
um
right
i guess one more thing about
giving a research presentation
um it's like like zlatko described
when you go to
do a presentation it's just it's just
like doing a interview talk
for a postdoc or professorship candidacy
usually you talk about some prior
research project
common to basically recycle your thesis
defense presentation right
but my piece of advice is that you need
to
communicate something technical and
prove that you could do that but you
also have the opportunity to share
more about yourself
and
what kind of a scientist are you what
kind of challenges have you
encountered and had to overcome
how do you
work with and appreciate other people
um if you can add little
anecdotes to that end
in there
more than just conveying
physics information
we really look for that
yeah yeah and i can maybe add to that
also like if you know because people
tell me oh you know people look for
culture fit i was like what you know
what does that even mean like what are
they actually you know talking about i
think a lot of times that's the kind of
thing where it's not like you have to
succeed it's not like you need an a plus
you just need a pass like you know
is this somebody that you know i could
see myself getting along with it's the
kind of thing that's more making sure
there's no red flags like this this
isn't just gonna you know derail the
mission and
so you know i think just don't over
stress about that as well
um and then i think like teresa said
yeah make sure that you know you're kind
of genuine yourself um and one thing
that i do notice folks sometimes in
interview processes though what
oftentimes will happen is they'll get
like stressed or freaked out but they
don't know the answer to something we
can't quite remember it
and
the point of these interviews isn't for
you to get it right most of the
companies they're just testing for the
boundaries of your knowledge
um and just getting a sense so actually
as the hiring managers or the
interviewers job oftentimes is to just
keep asking questions until you can't
answer anymore
um they just want to see where that
boundary is and if part of it is shallow
that's okay because you've probably got
another part that's deep and you can
help steer the conversation too you know
it's not always clear to to the hiring
person exactly who they're dealing with
you know they just had you know three
minutes right before this talk between
the other talk to like look at your cv
so you can help guide them as well i
mean these are things i'm strong ad
these are things i love to do
and the two of you can kind of work
together on that
and um yeah you know have
have energy have excitement um you know
don't let that stress kind of you know
really make you tense
and uh melanie you're you're our expert
on on that field can you give us some
advice and pointer on like what to do
because we had excellent uh advice from
teresa and zlatko on practice so like
how can you hack in students right now
who are looking for jobs um can can put
all the chance on their side to to to
land a position
so um i think that's an excellent
question florian and i have to say
everyone on the call today is
taking a great first step right they are
hearing from people who are in industry
they're hearing about
what
people in industry are looking for so
zlatko has you know some postings coming
open and you know he'll be hiring soon
and so it's good to hear from hiring
managers it's good to hear from teresa
about her experience on the job and what
her employer looks for and does and so
you can go through this exercise
on your own whether you're an
undergraduate or graduate student
postdoc or someone who's in
on the job market now through networking
and i think networking is critical to
anyone who's interested in
this field because
the more you can connect with scientists
who are doing the work now the more
you'll hear about how to prepare how do
you prepare to give a presentation how
do you prepare for a behavioral
interview what does that even mean
what kinds of questions might you hear
and theresa mentioned cultural fit what
does that mean and how will you ever
know whether you would match a
particular company's culture
that is all through talking with people
who are actively in the field now right
so you can do that through linkedin you
can do that through scientific societies
professional associations um you know
you can do that in many different ways i
know that yale actually has a very
robust alumni database and so you can
get in touch with people who are working
in
quantum science now
through possibly your institutions
alumni
office or the career center so
there are many different ways that you
can start to get into the field make
contacts in the field
even before applying for jobs you know
you can be online and you can be looking
at job postings and you can be applying
oh that's great let go that's that's
excellent so um
zlatko mentioned on the chat that he's
on the yale alumni database so
it's important and someone on the call
has already connected with me on
linkedin you know if you connect with
any of us then you'll be connected or be
able to see
all of our connections um so it's it's
important for you to start building out
your web of contacts
because that will help you once you do
see a posting that is interesting to you
in your field
you can start to apply
online
there's nothing wrong with applying
online first there's no harm in it it's
free
but the chances that you'll be called
back are so much more likely if you have
any connection at all with any
um person any scientist anyone who's
connected to that organization so um so
networking is the key i think
thank you and then um yeah you're
mentioning all the resources um so we
know fairly well the career resources at
uh saint joseph at yale and at the
university of arizona because we're
working with them but i'm sure for
anybody who is affiliated with any uh
university or any school you should be
able to to find similar resources in
your in your center um there we have a
question a couple of questions on on the
chat from the audience so we're talking
about like how to prepare for interview
but like also what are the skills that
are currently hard to find when people
are trying to hire new new quantum
employees like what are the skills that
are value for employers so i think this
is a more like i think it would depend
on the type of company but like do you
have a sense of like is there a gap in
the market and then people should go
into certain avenue like consider a
certain path because that's something
that you see in your industry was like
oh we wish we could have
that type of skills like what what could
be um what could be something that um
current students should look into
theresa do you want to swap around and
you go first this time
i can go first too well i don't have a
sense of the
whole quantum workforce market
um
uh do you want to talk for example uh
for like i'm gonna put in the
presentation i see that on your on your
websites on the quantum website section
of hlr you have a lot a lot of post of
job posting they're currently uh there's
20 uh 29 posts and so when you see this
thing it's mostly people with strong
background in in science so i think
one of the one of the things you need to
do is uh quantum is pretty rough uh it's
a pretty difficult topic and so having
strong uh strong solid knowledge in
physics
stem or engineering is something that uh
will be helpful and will also help you
transition to two other jobs um but yeah
if you um if uh like if you have more
yeah yeah i can jump in i mean there's
actually so there's like an entire field
of people working on identifying the
gaps in the workforce and workforce
development like workforce development
in of itself is like a whole thing you
can you know it's like a whole big um
part of ibm and big industry
um and so there was a lps co-laboratory
workshop uh i gave a little feature and
you know will oliver and all these other
people were there too from like industry
and uh government and all the sectors
right
and uh they're identifying the gaps
because there's so many different
positions so i think they're going to
have like an official big report and
that's going to have like
you know a very well digested version
i think some obvious things are just you
know just
quantum i mean just quantum skills in
general like you you know there's like
20 there's like 50 posts between hr and
ibm now that's a lot of posts right i
mean how many phd students get produced
per lab per year not a lot right so just
quantum basic 101 like understanding
quantum physics quantum algorithms to
some degree already is just a huge
gap
um so that's that's changing i mean even
at the masters level especially even at
the masters that when the undergrad
level that's like those jobs didn't
exist before but now there's a lot of
demand for those jobs like teresa said
you know we don't
not every single person needs a phd to
do their job you know the phd gives you
a lot of breadth of that but this is
great to add on
um
i think the other skill that you know i
think would help a lot is really just
software i mean
especially in quantum software is a huge
part of everything we do the way we run
experiments the way you go into the lab
almost everything is software controlled
anything higher level anytime you want
to work with uh whether it's you know
client or researchers or you want to do
anything it's usually through software
and that was a skill that you know like
half of our group was really into and
the other half was totally against
basically at the time you know in my
degree so
um you know having better sort of
developer software skills even if that's
not your primary role it's just such an
essential tool and it's
it really you know i see it in a lot of
candidates it's just it's not to the
level that it would really benefit them
um
and
you know i think another one is um
you know i think especially more you
know presentation skills are always very
important as well because you end up
having to present a lot but i think just
within quantum just understanding
quantum and different you know
understanding a little bit about quantum
computing on basics fundamentals uh some
quantum algorithms the basic level
this is this is all super helpful
um we actually have a question we you've
uh you've all been talking about
software and so we have questions from
the chat what is the difference between
applying to be a software engineer in a
big tech company which i think is
probably like thinking about like oh how
to develop like twitter facebook this
kind of like software needs and the
difference between being an actual uh
like software for quantum systems uh is
the is there like a difference and like
how do you get this because you can
start coding on like on python for your
mini mini app or something like this but
like how do you start coding on a
quantum system like how do you how do
you train yourself for that
um
i can go first three so whichever
um i guess something comes to my mind
and that's
that there's of course a wide variety of
software tasks associated with the
field of quantum
information
um and some of those are more
theoretical but on the experimental side
the stress on
the software is
more related to the interface
between the software and the hardware
because our hardware
of the quantum system is
in many implementations
inaccessible by
being at the level of
dilution refrigerator so um
doing the
quantum software is really doing a
special kind of classical software to
control whatever control electronics
there are whether it's control
electronics
at
the top of the fridge
or
advanced control electronics some
companies are doing cryogenic
controllers
and
software needs to be written to
control this very very specialized
hardware
and that is a unique skill that i
wouldn't say
is shared with the like app development
and stuff
it's very much needed
awesome yeah and uh i and i would add to
that right so
there's software that's lower down the
stack as you might say like closer to
the hardware usually that requires a lot
more domain knowledge like a lot more
expertise about usually need to have
worked in a in a lab not necessarily not
necessarily but usually you know to
actually understand the qubits what's
the writing rotation how does it work
what's pulse shaping pulses so if you
want kind of a more what a colloquially
called hardcore quantum software
developer position you really need to be
pretty good at that sometimes you know
there's a lot of work on compilers so in
that case you might need compiler
knowledge background as well or you can
pick it up on the job i have a good
friend who's absolutely excellent at if
you you know you just picked it up
um
but i think overall there's you know
there's definitely more of an emphasis
on quantum it's um it's probably a
little different in that i think you
know if you're going for a traditional
software role you're probably going to
get a lot more questions about software
architecture and like software design
you're going to have a software design
principle part of your coding interview
like
different model view controller
framework or you might get asked
questions like that whereas here i think
it's more like
you know
a mix between the quantum flavor and
the um
uh like do you have the right
abstractions can you build abstractions
correctly in place for that
um
and do you just have the operating
skills and can you work in an open
source
for part of industry can you work in an
open source environment or have you done
contributions to an open source repo do
you understand the open source ecosystem
that's part of yeah that's one big part
of industry because many of these
industries ibm in particular now it's
very open source based and that has a
slightly different flavor
um and you know obviously project
management and so forth like github and
all that as well
thank you
um we have an another question from the
chat um are there any uh opportunity
available for undergrads uh who to have
hands-on experience on quantum hardware
uh and like is the internship possible
and and like where do you find and i
think that could also be a question for
uh for millennia like where do you find
the resources and like is there like a
job posting both somewhere that
recognize that has all these
opportunities and and what could be i
know there's a ton uh these days there's
a ton of uh of hackathon happening all
over the world
um and so it's while it's not hands-on
on hardware you will still code onto
actual hardware uh through the cloud
system but um do you have any mention of
like what uh what students can do and is
there like
uh clubs or uh stuff in the uh or like
in opportunities for internship in
companies and where do you find this
so i'm so glad you mentioned that um
florian hackathons because you know the
ability to code and and having some
concrete evidence for any employer you
know of your skills is so
powerful it's so meaningful um so i
think that the more that students can
engage in that activity the better
in terms of
postings for internships
i would think carefully about where
you'd like to be geographically and then
look at local um quantum employers and
you know people who might have
internships available and go to their
websites directly
um i'm not as big a fan of big
broad job boards um as i am you know for
particular places like ibm or hrl uh
having their own posts
um so that's more you know i would be
more targeted in terms of where you'd
like to be geographically
and then target um some quantum
employers
yeah and i can probably also add to that
because you know uh
quantum soft quantum hardware design is
is kind of
a lot of my world um
i i would say you know look at what
projects are out there and try to get
involved
probably through open source and that
will often lead you to hackathons or
slack channels uh where you're gonna
meet and discuss and people will post
things um so for instance you know we
have several internships for kiskat
metal which software for quantum
hardware design
so you get to work you know with that we
designed a five-qubit device that's
going to the university of tokyo with
cascade metal
you know some folks from chalmers are
using it as well
um there's a summer school actually
i think it's quantum bc and canada and
and uh cmc microsystems
they um you know they had a they
organized a summer school with kisked
metal where you get to
design your quantum hardware then
actually gets fabricated and then you
measure it so these opportunities
actually exist some of them are more
regional some of them are more
international uh you know there's like a
global summer schools on that
um but if you kind of like contribute or
hang out um first of all you know if you
hang out in like a community like that
like a slack channel that's great but if
you're active and you contribute to a
cold base or something like that like
people who are working on that will
notice you immediately they're going to
know your name um and
you know if you ask internships like
people will reach out and actively help
you so i think that's always a great way
like melanie said you know
don't just go to like jobs.com and type
in this because you know you're going to
spend a lot of effort and your result
might just it's going to be a lot harder
that way
and and all these advice are valid for
people who are international so we are
all based in the us but um there's i
think since the since the pandemic a lot
of companies a lot of university have
moved towards online platforms and so
the while the hackathon that you could
take part was locally like people who
had to be in the same room now they're
like available to any countries in the
world like it's going to be a challenge
for the time zone sometimes but i think
some big companies
are hosting different uh hackathon for
different part of the world and one
thing that you get from out of this is
that you also build your network and so
uh people who the reason why these big
companies and university are hosting
this hackathon is really to get talent
and so
finding uh like finding a job uh is not
really uh just a hunt for for you as a
candidate you really like the company
needs to fill these places it's a need
to work and so it's not really you're
not fighting against industry to get
your job you really it's mostly a
collaboration and so if you can work
with your network and with the people
uh who are hosting the hackathon who are
judging uh who see that you you've
proved that you could do like some some
amazing coding or some amazing way of
like
processing a different signal uh in a
different way uh that's something that
they might keep in mind and then they
might post or they might follow up and
send you a job posting say like hey
that's something that you might be
interested in so um yeah the i think the
the geography while it's challenging is
not really a big barrier like there's a
shortage of quantum worker and so no
matter where you are in the world i
think if you have the talents you that
will find a way to to bring you to to
where you need to be um so that's and
that's also something
we had a lot of questions in the chat
about international students uh going on
this thing
um uh we have a few more questions one
is about um so that that's an
interesting question because it goes
between the the the few panels that we
had in the past um do you know of any
former co-worker who have branched out
of uh have branched out from industry to
startups and so what is the uh is there
a lot of lateral motion between these
two uh different system uh like can you
can you go from like industry to
startups and then come back and what uh
do you have any experience with that
like have you seen any people who have
done that
yes i've seen people go both directions
um i think it's uh just part of this
fairly small but growing world of
quantum in industry uh
i have friends that have gone both
directions
all right cool so that was a good thing
um we are almost uh at the at the end of
the of the panel so what i propose is
that um yeah well i'll give you the one
in second my videos we're like we're
gonna talk about uh one last uh topic
like what would be your your advice like
general advice and final remarks for
this thing but before we do that uh
matthews i see that you have your hand
raised um feel free to uh to answer
yeah maybe so
i guess my question is
from the perspective of a graduate
student a second year graduate student
who is actually considering to go for
academia and it's maybe a more personal
question so what was the point that made
you decide to go to industry
because at some point i guess how every
graduate student needs to make that
decision right so how
how how how did it happen for you
i can take this one first um so for me
it was like way after i got my job offer
actually i only applied to industry
as a as a
as a exploratory site option i was
primarily looking at doing post docs um
and uh and you know more traditional
path if you want so it was a bit of a
surprise actually finding myself giving
a career panel on on
work joining the workforce and industry
um
and uh
i i first of all i think my advice would
be from what i have seen there's about
like two percent correlation between
what a second year grad student and when
a sixth year grad student coming out of
their phd is thinking in terms of
academia versus industry so honestly i
just wouldn't worry about that very much
because almost every single person i
talked to they were like i'm 100 going
to industry i'm 100 going to academia or
academia sex academia is awesome
like by the time you're in your fourth
sixth year
you're a totally different person like
that stuff is like
so whatever you're thinking now
just forget you know it doesn't it it's
cool it's great you're thinking about it
i'm appreciative of that but honestly
just focus right now on developing
yourself to the best you can be in this
environment because if you're looking
over there but you're having to move in
this direction you're going to trip up
and industry is not going to
go as well as you want and academia
isn't i would say just develop yourself
i mean at the same time you know go to
career panels go to conferences build
that network that manila mentioned you
know talk to people in both sides and
get a good environment
but you do not have to make the decision
right now
[Laughter]
you do not have to choose right now and
whatever you choose right now it's you
know your ultimate destiny will work out
either way so that would be my first
advice um i think you know how did i
choose like i said you know i should
ended up choosing very late in the
process and i decided that
you know it's a very unique time in
quantum that's the other thing you
cannot predict i mean when i was in my
second year of the phd there was no
quantum industry i mean maybe ibm was
the only place or maybe there's like two
places or three places in the world that
had quantum teams in industry it didn't
even exist even in 2015 it was like you
know pretty late in my phd
i thought i didn't really think industry
was a thing in quantum
and so the landscape will change and you
have to adjust with that blueprint as
well um and so
i think at that time it seemed like you
know this is a once
in a
you know blue moon kind of potential
opportunity what's happening with
quantum if there's ever time to you know
be more adventurous and do an experiment
with my own career and my own life and
see how that goes and where that takes
me
this is this is the time and i decided
to go on a boat faith and leap and you
know explore this other pursuit knowing
that you know it may be a little more
difficult to sort of transition back to
academia proper if i wanted to
but that's always an option you know
these decisions aren't final
because we have seen people going from
industry to startup industry to academia
academic to startup academy you know
it's like all these pathways are
possible
and one thing that i want to add also is
that there's a ton of opportunities
you're not even aware of
and so if you really focus on on one
aspect of things like oh i want to work
on that field you might miss something
that's uh very interesting like for
example my i worked in higher ed
education like i'm doing more
program development for for quantum uh
for condom students and researchers and
it's something that i was not really
like i i was following the path of like
i want to i have a phd i want to become
a faculty member and then one day there
was this opportunity i was like oh that
sounds like an actual job that i would
like and so i think that's also
something to keep in mind is that this
panel are divided in like section
because we need to find way to find a
way to put them in boxes but um there's
also it's more like a continuum and i'm
going to make this corny joke about
quantum systems it's not on and off but
it's all of the above everything is like
mixed together and you have all these
opportunities uh that that can really
like come come your way um
and so uh yes so thank you so much for
uh taking the time of being on that
panel uh maybe we can do one last round
and then if you have last piece of
advice for all of our attendees uh that
would be uh they'll be wonderful and in
the the same times i will put on the um
on the on the slides if i can find my
slide against here we go on the slides
uh the the job hosting of your two
companies so people can have a look so
maybe let's start with you uh teresa uh
if you want to have a last word that
could also be like good luck
sure um
industry jobs in quantum fields are
definitely here
i think they're a pretty attractive
great option um for me my appetite was
wet for
doing
uh industrial r d probably before i
started graduate school because i worked
in a r d lab that was actually in
chemistry so i kind of knew that i
wanted to work in that environment
before starting my phd
um
yeah and now that i've been doing so at
a single company for five years and seen
remarkable progress in our technology
during my time here
i find that exciting
if you're interested in learning more
about quantum dot physics i encourage
you to find our papers and videos or we
have some videos of our conference
presentations on our website um
and we're hiring people from a variety
of backgrounds
check out our website
thank you very much
um so yeah you have the the slide on on
your screen uh select code do you want
to say a few more words
yeah awesome i mean theresa said it
perfectly um
really awesome so what what other words
do i have i think one don't stress out
honestly you're in like a golden age
um maybe
pause and just take a moment of
gratitude for
you know how awesome of a place you are
i mean if you're in this quantum seminar
like you you are you're in the golden
age uh you're really having a great time
uh and there's so many opportunities and
options and like florian theresa said
like you know i've been in industry for
a few years now and
i keep learning about new roles that i
didn't even know existed even within my
own company
there's just so many different varieties
and flavors opportunities
and i think with that i'll re-echo what
i said is like yeah you can start here
but at the end of the day i think your
greatest potential for
joy and happiness will be if you can
help define your own role uh down the
line within that as well
uh as much as possible
and yeah just you know reach out to
folks like teresa and me or your friends
and just
hear their stories that will really give
you a great map of the landscape
and
i'm sure you'll do great
thank you vadco uh melanie do you have a
few uh last bit of advice for our
attendees
sure uh just follow your passion you
know i think everyone has talked about
that uh on the call today and um
employee and i'm so glad that you shared
more information about your job because
there are so many opportunities out
there for students interested in
being around quantum talking about it
writing about it studying it um
contributing to the field you know there
are so many opportunities right now it's
like zlatko said this is a golden age uh
such an exciting time to be in quantum
so
i think i would really think about what
you like to do most and really pursue
that
so thank you so much for having me of
course my pleasure
uh and then uh while we conclude uh this
is the list of all the uh all the panels
that we had in the past um so we had we
tried to to cover everything uh from how
to go uh how to prepare and choose
courses uh in um
for college how to do uh how to prepare
for grad school how to grow a faculty
and we also had one for startups and so
all of these video will be available uh
on replay uh on the the yell youtube
channels so thank you uh very much and
i'm putting the link in the chat also if
you want to
uh thank you very much uh for your time
thank you all uh to uh to for sharing
your experiences and and helping and
helping us understand uh what it's like
to to work in industry and thank you all
for attending these uh these seminars i
hope you uh have a wonderful evening and
a great weekend thank you